everyone very very warm welcome from me
as well to this intelligent squared plus
event
um with me Anita farahani as we're
casting in as we are from different
hotel rooms uh around the world uh Nita
is Professor of Law and philosophy at
Duke and she's a founding director of
the Duke Initiative for Science and
Society
um and from 2010 all the way through
2017 she served as commissioner on the
U.S presidential commission for the
study of bioethical issues and on the
board of advisors for Scientific
American
um and her brilliant new book which of
course we're going to be discussing
today is Battle for your brain defending
the right to think freely in the age of
neurotechnology so and I'm sure you're
all very familiar uh with this by now
um me and Nita are going to be talking
for about 40 minutes or so and then it's
going to be over to you for questions so
do start writing those in the tab do
tweet two uh and then I'll get to you uh
before too long I promise uh Anita very
very warm welcome to you thank you it's
a pleasure to join you today
awesome all right well the first
question is going to be
um uh hopelessly uh a a crude or simple
to begin tell us what brain waves are
what this is all actually you know in
its raw Essence about
sure
um and I should say uh we'll say brain
data more generally because they're
brain waves which is uh something that I
talk a lot about in the book but there's
also other forms of brain data that can
be collected so
um you know as you think as you do a
math calculation as you listen to music
as you do anything experience anything
um it there are representations of that
in the brain and that can come in the
form of brain waves that is as you think
or experience something neurons are
firing in your brain which give off tiny
electrical discharge
um and the like when you have a big
thought any kind of thought any kind of
say hundreds of thousands of neurons are
firing at the same time giving off
concurrent electrical discharges that
can be picked up and detected through
sensors that are applied to the scalp or
through a device that picks up
oxygenation levels in the brain and
changes in oxygenation level in
different regions of the brain and so
brain waves are the different
frequencies and amp dudes of the
different firings of neurons in your
brain and those happen in characteristic
patterns that as AI gets better and
better can actually be deciphered and
decoded so as you're thinking what is
Nita going to say next there are neurons
firing in your brain which have
different amplitudes and frequencies and
different brain waves and those can be
detected with something called
electroencephalography or EEG which are
just sensors that pick up that activity
I know I I know what you mentioned it
just before you're joined by everyone a
new nature study uh which is um uh which
is kind of exposing how um a kind of a
machine learning based forms of
interpretation are moving forward so I
know it's moving forward very quickly
but just give us a sense of of just how
kind of uh rapid now the the kind of
capabilities that we have to read brain
data are are advancing
sure so you know with EEG or
electroencephalography you're picking up
basic brain waves which
um can tell basic brain states are you
happy are you sad are you paying
attention is your mind wandering are you
bored or engaged
um you know do you have a positive or A
negative response to some kind of
stimulus what we were talking about just
a few moments ago is much more advanced
technology that can peer more deeply
into your brain so the use of something
like functional magnetic resonance
imaging so people are familiar with
these giant MRI machines that can image
inside of the body fmri can image what's
happening inside of the brain in
particular what's functionally happening
inside of the brain so
um as you are thinking thoughts uh
different regions of the brain are
active and so blood flows into a region
and flows out of the region as it flows
into the region it's carrying oxygen
that oxygen is consumed by the brain
activity in that region which means the
deoxygen native blood flows out of it
and that can be picked up those
differences the blood oxygenation levels
can be picked up by functional magnetic
resonance imaging
now most people thought that it was too
slow of a measure the blood flow into
and out of a region as opposed to EEG
which is the rapid firing to be able to
decode thoughts literally The Continuous
language that you experience in the
brain and researchers out of Texas just
published a paper in nature yesterday on
May the 1st to show that by using the
advances in AI in particular generative
AI so they use gpt1 to predict what the
next word is based on brain activity
data that they could decode continuous
language and semantic content not
literally word for word although
oftentimes literally word for word but
the entire meaning of a sentence the
meaning of a sentence as well being
decoded based on brain activity they
then wanted to see if the you know fmris
are not something that we're going to
have in our everyday lives they're big
numbers of machines they're incredibly
expensive to have people into them they
wondered whether or not knots with
non-invasive meaning something that's
not implanted in the brain would it be
possible to use the same model the
classifier that they had trained on
people's brain activity to be able to
decode using F nears functional near
infrared spectroscopy and this is a
light shined through the skull which
based on the diffusion of the light an
infrared light through the skull picks
up different kind of tissue Dynamics
again it's picking up this oxygenation
levels in the brain and they found that
their classifier worked on F nears as
well which could be far more portable in
fact I'll show you this is a portable F
nears device which literally you can
just wear you know across the forehead
like this and it picks up brain activity
now this isn't the device that they were
using to trade it on but presumably
something even like this could start to
pick up thoughts and thought activity it
just has these sensors here which shine
light through the brain through the
skull and pick up that activity as you
engage in different activities so that's
the kind of remarkable study and part of
why it's so remarkable is that up until
now basic words or phrases or images had
been decoded from the brain but not
continuous language not imagined
thoughts themselves meaning actual mind
reading is is possible I'll just add one
caveat to that which I know we'll get
into the discussion of issues of mental
privacy the study itself looked at
whether or not
um people could employ counter measures
to it and it also looked to see whether
a system trained on one person's brain
could be used on another unwilling
participant like are all of our brain
activities the same and they found that
no it goes down to basically chance to
decode brain activity trained on one
person on another person and that you
could consciously Implement
countermeasures those are good first
steps they're trying to figure out the
extent to which this could really
compromise mental privacy for people who
are burst into using the technology
doesn't really answer what happens when
people willingly use it which is what I
foresee is the coming future
and just for the benefit of our podcast
future podcast this is uh Nita was
holding a kind of narrow things it looks
quite light kind of it looks like a
headband in many ways with kind of just
thin are they kind of magnetic strips
neater on the inside yeah so I mean so
what this is I mean this is maybe like
about an inch and a half thick wide
plastic headband that's worn across the
forehead on the inside there's just this
rubber
um you know kind of uh piece that has a
few different light sources four
different light sources here
um that when used just uh basically
sends light through the skull into the
brain to pick up brain activity as it
um is diffused across different brain
tissue based on different amounts of
oxygen being consumed in different
regions of the brain and this just pairs
with an app on a phone
um to pick up basic meditation States
that's not trained on the classifier
that we were just talking about it'll be
very interesting to see if a device like
this one and could have much more
sophisticated software to do much more
sophisticated decoding from the brain so
just to boil down then where where we
are and where we're getting to when it
comes to I guess brain transparency or
interpretation of brain data right now
if people are using these devices
they're they're broadly reading great
like they're mind States today whether
they're relaxed or concentrated or or
happy or things like that and are we
moving then towards a world where it's
maybe specific
actually formed thoughts
someone imagining something or someone
thinking a word or a sentence these are
the these are going to be the things
that become decipherable next as these
as these classifiers become more
powerful I think that's right the
question Still Remains an open question
of how much can a portable device pick
up as opposed to the large cumbersome
devices but the proof of concept in a
large cumbersome device for actual
thought decoding is now here right I
mean published in nature there was
another study that was published about a
month ago that did image decoding from
the brain using stable diffusion which
is again a form of generative AI to try
to figure out if new advances in AI
would enable much more sophisticated
decoding So based on today's technology
for portable devices it's brain States
for Less portable but still non-invasive
devices like fmri already it's possible
to decode images that a person is
imagining thoughts in terms of
continuous language and Inter monologue
imagine thought that a person is having
and so you know is the bridge between
those big cumbersome devices and these
smaller portable devices a long bridge
or a short Bridge it seems like with how
quickly generative AI is moving and the
advances in that space and if it's
possible to have devices like the one
that I was showing this F nears device
it may be a lot closer than people
realize
I mean I have to say we're living in a
moment where I think we're all realizing
every day moments where the realities of
the present collide with our ideas of
Science Fiction and and things we
thought impossible but but actual
real-time mind reading for me at least
is is is one of the most powerful
moments of all of just thinking this is
just it is just so insane that we're
close to be able to being able to do
these kinds of things
I mean I agree right so having written
this book and lived with neurotechnology
for quite a while and thought about
these issues for quite a while it's less
alarming to me already right it's more
normalized for me than I think for many
but in this moment when people are
really struggling with I think the
existential crises that so many are
facing with respect to like what does
generative AI mean for Humanity what
does it mean to be human what does it
mean to be living in an age in which so
much of our Lives
um are interdependent with these
Technologies to then say like and also
they can decode what's literally
happening in your mind
um I think is incredibly startling for
people and you know that's why I wrote
this book as both a wake-up call for
people to realize what's happening with
neurotechnology today the promise of it
but also the Peril of it and so you know
I think most people feel like oh my gosh
how are we ever going to catch up with
regulation or laws or Norms with respect
to generative AI we're still at a moment
but before with neurotechnology
happening at scale across Society but I
I think we're literally at a moment
before it going to scale across Society
because we've been talking about the
devices generally what's coming now is
um the sensors being part of everyday
devices so I have on airpods right now
um and I showed you a headband that most
of us are not likely to go through our
lives wearing on a day-to-day basis
um but the devices are now coming in the
form of sensors for EEG where the
sensors are embedded in earbuds and
headphones and even watches that pick up
brain activity as it travels down you
know your arm to your wrist and pick up
your intention to move or to type or to
swipe and so in the same way that people
are wearing watches the pickup heart
rate or rings that pick up their
temperature or breaths or sleep activity
so too will brain activity be picked up
through these multifunctional devices
and that you know when that happens
which is all being launched within the
next few months
that really will take this to scale in
society so we have a moment uh where
it's kind of the moment before where at
the moment after for generative AI going
to scale across Society where at the
moment before of neurotechnology going
to scale across Society
and in that in that moment just before
we as consumers collide with this what
what's kind of happening in the kind of
I guess the commercial front then uh are
we seeing like the very large b2c
companies currently like gobbling up the
labs is that is that currently you know
exactly how does the lab so I mean
there's there's a lot of commercial
small neurotech companies who've been
developing these centers for quite a
while or developing the technology and
the products for a while one of the
first major Acquisitions in this space
happened in 2019 so
um in 2018 I saw a presentation by a
company then called control Labs where
what they were demonstrating was an
early prototype of a watch or bracelet
um where what it could do was pick up
brain activity as I was describing going
down your arm to your wrist and pick up
your intention to type on a keyboard
um to enable you then to type on a
virtual keyboard or not even type but to
think about typing and to decode from
your intention to type or to communicate
from your wrist
um and that was the first I'd really
seen the embedding of a sensor in a form
that could be part of our everyday
devices and it was the first time I'd
seen
um an illustration of the technology in
a way that was more about interfacing
with other Technologies rather than a
standalone application so neural
interface could be about you trying to
see your own brain activity are you
stressed are you relaxed are you tired
or could be how like picking up your
intention to swipe and type to replace
your keyboard in your mouse and they
were illustrating it for that purpose is
the way you interface with other
Technologies meta acquired that company
in 2019
um at for somewhere between 500 million
to a billion US dollars that was the
first of these major Tech announcements
of the investment by big tack into
neurotechnology as part of neural
interface since then Google Microsoft
Apple all of them have either acquired
neurotech companies or significantly
scaled their own efforts in the space to
develop sensors of their own and so what
you see is both a gobbling up of the
smaller neurotech companies like Snap
recently acquired a company out of Paris
called Next mines to integrate neural
sensors into the r their augmented
reality devices that they're developing
and so that's what you're saying you're
seeing either the acquisition of talent
the acquisition of the smaller neurotech
companies who've developed this specific
neural sensors or the in-house
capability that's rapidly developing
within each of the institutions
themselves
so need to let's now get to the threat
the kind of the hazard that is upon us
um because I mean I very much read your
book as a as a wake-up call
um of course you know where you've got
the kind of autocrats and the
surveillance capitalists and hackers and
the the kind of you know centers of
state power and surveillance all kind of
in a way like in this new kind of Gold
Rush with our brain data right in the
middle
um so so what if if things don't change
what's the kind of fear that you have
for for what will happen as these
consumer devices get rolled out on
everyone's brain data becomes starts
getting recorded
yeah
let me say before I answer that directly
Carl I'm first going to take on the like
why in the world would anybody choose to
use one of the devices because it helps
better inform uh the threat of it as
well which is
um people are very used to tracking now
their heart rate their breasts their
sleep their body temperature
um and yet they have almost no
information about what's happening in
their own brains and the possibilities
of being able to track everything from
your stress levels to you know potential
cognitive decline over time for somebody
who's an epileptic to be able to get you
know information about an epileptic
seizure minutes to an hour before it
occurs to detect the earliest stages of
glioblastoma or Parkinson's or any of
the neurodegenerative diseases or to
have new tools to be able to fight
depression or mental health disorders or
drug use disorders at scale I think will
be transformational for people even just
be able to know like do I really focus
better at home in this hotel room or you
know in my office setting and to have
real metrics of information about
yourself I think is the reason why
people will use it and then as the
companies invest in it being the way
that you interface much more seamlessly
and with less friction with other
technology so you think about sending a
text message instead of typing it with
your thumbs which is much faster and
more efficient and by the way maybe you
can do it while you're driving a car and
it's safer as well right these are the
ways in which I think people start to
adopt it
all of the major tech companies all of
the investment in the space recognizes
the huge Market potential which is you
know brain sensors don't exist in our
everyday technology we're not
quantifying brain health in the same way
that we treat the rest of our physical
health and so the possibility just as a
market segment to sell the devices
themselves is bringing a huge number of
Corporations to the table so in this
kind of rush to see who can sell the
devices who can Corner this Market I
mean you almost sold me right right
about
um enhances right and and how it can
make you you know neurofeedback might be
able to help you learn I think we'll
clearly concentrate better and I was
reading that and I was thinking this
sounds absolutely brilliant
well embrace it for those reasons I
think the the upside potential will lead
people to rush to it I also think that
they will when it's in your earbuds or
your headphones the risks will become
invisible to them and so what are those
risks one is the surveillance capitalism
economy is about commodifying data and
the gold mine of data that is brain data
is what like all of the companies
recognize it and so the commodification
of brain data has already begun by these
smaller neurotech companies now imagine
like you're a meta and you can say to an
Advertiser I can give you not just what
they're clicking likes on or how much
time they're spending on their device or
how they scroll through something but
literally how their brain reacts to your
advertisement right I mean that's gold
for MATA and so to be able to modify
brain data as people are on devices or
interacting with their environment or
interacting with software of course is
part of it right but that means that how
you think and feel your biases your
emotions all of that which is being at
some ways inferred from your everyday
activities with a much greater degree of
precision can start to be commodified by
companies and it's one thing to
recognize that the person decision of
micro targeting and manipulation of
behavior that can occur at scale is
frightening then you look at the way
governments can misuse this as well
whether that is like you know
intelligence agencies who are already
spy on phones or emails can start to spy
on brain activity or law enforcement
worldwide who are already interrogating
brains of criminal suspects using
neurotechnology and can start to do so
with much greater precision and at scale
to the chilling effect it has on freedom
of speech right surveillance there have
been lots of studies that have been done
that show that government surveillance
chills people's willingness to speak up
to express dissident views when people
are required to wear brain devices in
the workplace which again is already
happening in a number of workplaces
worldwide is already happening in
regimes like China where State Workers
are required to wear brain surveillance
devices to pick up their brain activity
to see if they are tired or awake or
paying attention or bored or engaged but
are also being used to interrogate their
brains whether it's to discover
information about people or to chill
their variability to think dissident
thoughts or big thoughts or any thoughts
whatsoever I think the risks are
profound
do you think we're in this is another
one of those circumstances where
um technology brings kind of oppressions
and liberations kind of wrapped up
together in this kind of fiendishly
um kind of uh complicated and naughty
way which means it's very very hard for
us to kind of disentangle
um a one from the other in a way to
either stop or or change direction
I think yes and no so on the one hand I
think the bad comes with the good right
I mean introducing an era of Greater
brain transparency means that your brain
is now available to you to be able to
know a lot more about your doctor to
know more about but also corporations
and governments to know much more about
also other people in society the no part
of it is it doesn't have to be that
employers and corporations and
governments have access to the data
right that's just been our default mode
of operation with respect to all of the
data that has been aggregated and
commodified and collected about
individuals over time but what if we did
it differently what if we decided this
is a new category of Technology this is
a new frontier the final frontier for
Humanity for privacy and for mental
privacy and for self-determination over
our brains and mental experiences and as
that final frontier we should approach
it differently before it goes to scale
across Society we should put into place
different rules and regulations and
treat it differently we should require
that brain data be overwritten on device
that individuals have the option for
multifunctional devices to turn off a
switch that says brainwave data should
not be collected now while I'm on this
conference call or this webinar or this
podcast or talking to my friend or loved
one or having an intimate conversation
right there are basic choices we could
make now that could fundamentally change
the trajectory of this so that it really
is mostly upside right there's always
misuse there's always downsides of
Technology there's always Bad actors but
we could make choices that would
substantially limit the effects of it
well let's let's talk about those
choices well let's talk about the
Frameworks neat because um well I can
already see there's a question uh in the
chat about
um George Orwell but before we get there
let's introduce another kind of
important thinker
um uh John Stewart Mill because I know I
know that Mill one and kind of
consequentialists like liberal
philosophy is very important to your
thinking so why did you enlight on
Millers as being one of the kind of main
philosophical
signposts for you to kind of navigate
this this Terrain
um it's a good question so I mean my my
thoughts on this were really
what we need is not neurotech rights and
AI rights and metaverse rights what we
need is an update to our basic
conception of what Liberty means in the
digital age
um and John Stuart Mill's book on
Liberty really looks you know closely
and and his seminal in this idea of like
what is Liberty
um and what is fundamental to it and the
way in which he really navigated that
question looking at the autonomy of
individual over self and then uh the
self vis-a-vis society and self Visa
government and the basic conceptions
around freedom of thought to me spoke a
lot to how I've been thinking about
the relationship of individuals to self
with the ability to access the
information about themselves their own
brain data vis-a-vis society and here
I'm thinking of Corporations and others
having access to your brain data and
vis-a-vis governments and the potential
interferences with it so that seems like
a good starting place to think about Bo
is what is a broad conception of an
update of Liberty in the digital age and
what's the missing piece right if you
read on Liberty Mill imagined the world
in which our brains could not be
accessed that we had the Solace of the
minds that freedom of thoughts if you
could hear a diversity of ideas that you
would have the private space to be able
to ruminate and to think about and to be
able to develop your own perspective he
didn't Imagine This World In which that
might not be possible and most theories
of human flourishing have always assumed
that the autonomy of self over brain and
mental experiences was robust and would
remain in a world in which that isn't
true and which is no longer possible it
seems like mill is a starting place for
Liberty to think about on cognitive
Liberty was the right beginning point
for the theory
what would the theory say so so a kind
of an updated Mill what would that what
would that give us now would it would it
be friends it turns out we need to go
farther than Mill to really have an
updated Theory but okay go ahead please
yeah well no so okay so so your
framework then
um borrowing from it and and lots of
other people too in your own ideas how
would that what how would that
meaningfully guide both the development
the technology and I I suppose the the
rights and opportunities that consumers
and individuals have around brain data
and how it's used
yeah so I you know it's the way that
I've been kind of framing it is to say
cognitive Liberty is both a right to
self-determination that is a right to
access information about our own brains
to change them if we choose to do so
um but also a right from a right from
interference with our mental privacy and
our freedom of thought
um and understanding the kind of
landscape this way the idea of the right
to self-determination really derives
more from something like John Locke
which is the idea of self-ownership and
self-governance that's the starting
place for Democratic systems the
starting place for human flourishing
begins with this idea of self-ownership
and self-determination but that idea
this kind of positive
um aspect of Liberty in the digital age
is there are huge benefits to
Technologies humanity is moving in the
direction of a much greater
interrelationship with technology and
the right to be able to use those
Technologies to change our mental
experiences to enhance as you said you
were drawn to the ability to be able to
enhance your own brain right that's part
of what we do as humans and so it's not
just a right to non-interference it's a
right to the positive aspects and to be
able to use and access and change our
brains and experiences through the use
of Technologies and interactions with
them but importantly a right from
interference requires that we have a
much more robust understanding of
concepts of privacy as a relative right
meaning there are some times in which
societal interventions into brains and
mental experiences will make sense but
mental privacy would mean our automatic
reactions our emotions our very thoughts
would be protected against unwarranted
intrusions and then a much narrower
aspect of the theory is freedom of
thought so freedom of thought right now
as it's understood in international
human rights law primarily focuses on
religion and belief there's been very
important work that's been done in this
space both by other Scholars and also by
the previous mandate holder to the UN
Declaration of Human Rights for freedom
of thought which was Dr Ahmed Shaheed he
presented a report in October of 2021 to
the U.N General Assembly arguing that
our conception of freedom of thought
really needs to be expanded to address
interception manipulation and punishment
for our thoughts and I think that makes
a lot of sense the question then is just
how do we define thoughts and here I
think thought is the really narrow
sliver of robust thoughts and images in
our minds because we try to read others
Minds all the time we try to manipulate
other people all the time we try to
persuade other people all the time we
don't want to interfere with ordinary
human interactions but we do want to
save Artists Against interference with
our very thoughts and images in our
minds